In our code, we're going to initialize
the adapter
within the Placeholder Fragment
onCreateView method.
Because that's where we want the ListView
to be populated with data.
We're using a ArrayAdapter, and we can
initialize it with four parameters:
A context,
the ID of a list item layout,
the ID of a text view within that list item layout,
as well as a list of data.
We'll go through each of these
parameters one by one now.
First, for context -- it contains global
information about the app environment.
It allows us to access system
services and resources,
as well as the application specific
resources that we've defined.
We use the fragments containing
activity as the context.
So, we're going to call getActivity
for our parameter here.
Since the adapter needs to know
the layout for each list item,
it needs some reference
to the XML layouts that we've defined.
The r.java class is a generated file
that creates human readable identifiers
for our resources.
For the list item layout, we refer to it
in code as R.layout.list_item_forecast.
This was the name of the XML file
that we created earlier.
Next, the array adapter needs to know
how to take the weather forecast string
and set that to be displayed
in a text view.
So you pass in the ID of the text view
that we defined earlier,
in the list item layout.
Even though these two
resource IDs look similar,
one starts with R.layout
while the other starts with R.id.
R.layout refers to a layout file, while
an ID refers to a specific XML element
with the matching ID attribute.
And lastly, we pass in weekForecast,
which is the array list of forecast data
that we defined earlier.
Now go ahead and initialize your adapter.
Check this box when you're done.